wir sind in silverstone wir sind in
england zum großen preis von
großbritannien
hier ist alles ein bisschen anders für
die formel 1 für die formel 1 teams
bekannter auf der einen seite sieben von
zehn teams haben hier in der nähe der
rennstrecke oder jedenfalls in england
ihre basis und doch ist es ein bekanntes
bild was sie sehen werden es werden zwei
silberne autos in der ersten startreihe
stehen weitere potters heute im
qualifying um die winzigkeit von sechs
tausendstelsekunden schneller als sein
teamkollege lewis hamilton platz sechs
nur für sebastian vettel im zweiten
ferrari deutlich geschlagen das dritte
mal nacheinander von le claire im
qualifying und viertel wie nord und der
teamchef ferraris teamchef matthias otto
sagten anschließend vettel habe sich nie
wohl gefühlt im auto
dass ein bekanntes bild in dieser saison
vettel und der sfz 90 ha das passt aus
einem grund nicht zusammen der
offensichtlich schwer zu finden ist
vettel sagte am donnerstag hier mal
läuft ist ein bisschen besser mal läuft
es wieder ein bisschen schlechter hier
in silverstone eher schlechte ferrari
startet auf weichen reifen die
konkurrenz die hauptkonkurrenz mercedes
red bull auf der mittleren mischung in
der taktik könnte noch ein weg nach
vorne liegen aber insbesondere für
sebastian vettel ist dieser weg sehr
sehr weit die frage die die 140000 hier
vor allem umtreibt wird sein ob hamilton
zum sechsten mal diesen großen preis von
großbritannien gewinnt das wäre eine
fahrt in die geschichtsbücher der formel
1 das kann man schon so sagen denn
niemand hat bisher dieses rennen mehr
als fünfmal gewonnen das gelang bislang
nur hamilton eben jim clark dem schotten
den franzosen alain prost
sechsmal hat hier noch niemand gewonnen
und es wäre ein weiterer rekord für
hamilton auf dem weg ganz nach vorne in
sämtliche rekordlisten das bild das die
formel 1 in diesem jahr
in den allermeisten fällen zeichnet das
zeichnet sich hier auch in silverstone
ab mercedes ist kaum zu schlagen